let's find out
i've really really enjoyed watching this
king uh play it's just so many good
fundamental king uh skills and abilities
that have been worked on for some time
by the looks of it and this kuni mitsu
is looking incredibly strong as well
as patients starting off with the
shenanigans
it's gonna be interesting to see what
what bumblebee really did well against
galander which is exploit his match up
in familiarity and get that going i'll
be interested to see if greetings uh
knows more is able to play around that a
lot and i like that they didn't have to
obviously look there um but then she'll
do that with two two into teleport so
you have to watch out for that there it
is
for fro again
two throw set two
no very nice
sometimes it's not punishable at the
perfect range it can be minus nine i
believe usually it's more nice in the
back
we had to duck that one there
set three
doesn't finish it again you could eat a
massive hit for doing that but
bumblebees playing more reserved
driving just the two options look very
nice
[Music]
that
doesn't finish it again
a little bit predictable here going for
the giant swing with his back to the
wall needs to switch it up finishes it
but doesn't and then he gets the giant
swing anyway yeah this is going to put
bumblebee in rage and it's going to be a
very scary situation more mix does it
oh interesting choice
one throw broken
oh but the back to drop kick very nice
there by greetings one one in rounds
that's the thing king does have back
turn moves and can use them they're
quite some of them quite evasive upward
four
against getting deja vu here four
forward one
swing nice break there by bumblebee
instant shiny wizard straight after
uh plus one plus two you can get okay
off this
tech roll nice
dude no punished on it
i feel like greetings is just scared to
let it go and there it is the teleport
there's gonna be big damage we're going
to the wall as well
what's the follow-up here
set three a yeah and just like that
bomby looking super strong here
trying to get him to duck but not
working
swing again needs to mix it up more
not the best punishment here from
greetings can get a lot more yeah i
could get back one two
three again and this is gonna go to the
no drops the combo a one plus two though
not broken does he know the okey kunai
no he backroad there could have been a
free kunai yeah
four two one is it this time but it
doesn't duck it this is not looking good
for greetings not at all for 2-1 again
he's looking a bit desperate right now
blocks the mangy kick sir
punish that no punish
oh and just like that bumby will take
the first game and yeah i'm i'm seeing a
lot of match up and for melody again
here for for greetings you know one two
two no punish he's not ducking correctly
um
i feel like people are just they're not
ready for kuni mitsu today everyone
everyone focused on laws everyone's
looking at mob okay we have to learn
lars in the background bumblebee was
just like practicing his kingdom soon
and no no one saw that coming so you
know greetings gonna need to switch up
here if he wants to uh take this because
cooney is kind of running over him right
now
yeah i agree there were a lot of jab
punishes where there could be more than
that that one two for example and the
thing about the back one two punish as
you saw in one of the previous games um
is that you actually get
pretty much a guaranteed mix up there
after you i mean you're going for a four
or three you're going for a throw you
can use those frames to actually get
some good movement in and get around
them there's all sorts of things you can
do but if you're not getting that bad
one too there's so many so much extra
damage that you're missing out on just
doing jabs isn't really enough there
needs to take take that damage where he
can i'd say the other thing is there was
a lack of creativity which i think if
you're playing at this level with king
you've
really got to have you can't just be
doing those canned mix-ups into into a
mid or versus a throw you've got to
switch timing up you've got to do more
than just doing the giant spring with
you back to the wall um and i think he's
even got to switch his timing and
creativity up here we'll just completely
switch
yeah i mean getting predictable king can
always be a pain but we are going to
forgotten from the true party stage
this is this is where king can really
let loose and have some funky things
happen so if uh
if greetings wants to win this he needs
to make his claim here right now
he does indeed interesting choice not
all king players like to pick this stage
yes they get ridiculous damage but it
does also sometimes make them a bit
predictable
so we'll see how this plays out
i mean i just wanted
some crazy crazy king shenanigans right
now let's just let's just get let that
happen right what's danny two two
nice punish it better no launch on this
set three there
one third broken though oh my gosh
they're both doing their their unique
movement
he's looking to get in and do a throw i
can feel it i could feel it in my bones
ah
duck into an end to full crotch 4-2
nice
it's really going down oh my goodness
oh but no can't get a combo as well ah
nice done
too okay
greetings coming up and there's the hot
knee
is
needless to use the floor though i think
a king purist would say don't bust
through that floor if you don't need to
but
good enough gets the round
foot forward one
four three
nice magic four options select
very nice went for the ground break
throw didn't get it very nice awareness
okay nice punishment this time back one
two in the while signing three it's
coming live now
set three again that is zero one hit
eating all the mix-ups right now
this hurts
break it
i think he could go for a jump over trap
here guys there's nothing to do it
frankenstein it doesn't work out rage
available and there it is for bumblebee
on the board here and all the flaws are
gone
yeah i don't think they've been used
optimally be tough here but let's see
what happens straight out bumblebee gets
gets the launch and will get the wall
very tough here for greetings
very nice setup as well looks like i
could even have got more while stunning
two two doesn't take the frames and eats
the launch that is so unfortunate and it
just looked like he lost confidence in
himself to go in and get the mix-up
round
zombie just looking so good right now
could make this a quick when the
greetings doesn't wake up
not stuck again
nice punishment now for one two that is
minus ten but there is the last hit of
the string you have to worry about
nice with punish
four three
oh nine for the right
nice patience there on the wall standing
game
again doesn't finish it
punish things are looking good greetings
can steal this round and the cartwheel
okay
up 4-3 such a good end of round option
now two rounds a piece it's just gonna
go to a final game
set two
oh this is great awareness but it
doesn't finish it
tombstone that's it need to see more of
that less giant swing could have got a
ground throw
well not the best punish them for when
you do is minus 14 can get whilst any
one one
one throw broken
again same situation
even with it reverse doesn't matter
king can get crazy here no it doesn't do
any of
the locks
oh nice spinny step
bumble bee can he steal this one plus
two though nice break there by greetings
set two into the hop and he does work
out great punish
downfall one just trying to keep it safe
great no parry by uh bumblebee though
but the wall's not gonna help him the
mangy kicks down forward one and the
alley kicks to end there we all tied up
one to one
belt are coming the alley kick is it's
actually not a bad option with your back
towards the wall like that because if
they launch you for it um you're
probably still alive so it's not not a
bad situation at all yeah
this is set up very nicely i feel like
uh king got away by the skin of his
teeth a little bit there at times there
were a few situations where it could
have easily gone the other way i think
bumblebee has reason to still feel
confident
yeah i agree i mean and that was that
was his stage pick as well and that was
still a very very close game you know
the forgotten realm still working out
very nice there for bumby now he'll be
happy about that but we're going to go
for the infinite stage now as well you
know if i love king's game and can you
miss me can you mix who's movement is
also really good for it so it'll be
interesting to see how that plays out
definitely definitely still i think
greetings is still very much
in this there are situations where they
looked super super confident and they
did start to get more creativity in play
we're going for other throws other than
the giant swing and maybe an infinite
stage will actually make him think more
and not you know think okay i've got my
back to the wall i'll do a giant swing
i'll do about one two into four or three
sometimes that can loosen the player up
when it's infinite because they know
that there isn't a reason for them to
gravitate towards one certain option
exactly and we sort of do we serve you a
lot it was very well with the walls in
place so be interesting to see how
greetings plays without them
uh now like you saw him do some crazy
things in his earlier game you know
against mob with the walls in play but
now now they're most like i'm i was
speaking like we see the stage already i
feel like bumble's gonna throw like some
kind of kerbal something like arena or
something
um but if that is the case it's gonna be
insane uh because bumblebees you know
aggression i feel like well this is the
first time today we've seen someone
finally counter bumblebee's aggression
force him to play defense force him onto
the back foot and that's what it just
looks like he isn't comfortable so you
know it'll be interesting to
to see how that plays out uh moving
forward
yeah i just feel like there's some moves
that cooney has against king think it's
um while standing three the the the the
the somersault kick that looks like it
probably should be more punishable than
it is
i just think those moves actually
the amount of risk versus reward versus
a king player so much in kuni mitsu's
favor the and we saw him check it out
quite a few times sometimes it was
blocked it wasn't fully punished
sometimes it was punished but a bit late
but that's that all stacks up against
the king player and in the meantime
you're getting a move where it crushes
heavily it isn't launch punishable and
you can kind of speculatively throw it
out here and there um and i think that
that can go in kunic's favor there's a
lot of crushing there a great back dash
back dash away from throws
um yeah it's it can be quite quite tough
looking
yeah um and the way bumblebee's playing
as well is like really i feel like he
hasn't let the aggression follicle yet i
want to see more full crouch down for
threes and sweeps like that just sort of
tested because once that low hits and it
hits from like range two very far away
it can be really scary um once that move
starts hanging you're already mixed up
you're already scared because you know
you see the ranger you're like i
shouldn't normally have to duck from
this kind of range but couldn't miss you
forces you to do that the flop will
forward forward too then it's the dash
forward you know then it's a back turn
mix up you know it really gets the party
star just one of those is really
important it's kind of i kind of like
it's like a kazuya's health street you
know the moment because he is house
sweet the party begins because you can't
stay down here's ford ford four which is
uh safe now i can't hit launch because
we've had mash
um then you get up you're taking another
mix it's gonna be the house again is it
gonna be uh one of them it's gonna be
downfield one two you know it's or the
down back two is quite scary to deal
with so that's that's kind of how i like
in uh kinematics for crash down four
three just with a lot more range as well
and it truly high crushes so
bumblebee has switched to the ling
i don't know like this
likes it because of this match up i know
this is a terrible match of the king
yeah true um however
you only lost a close final round on
forgotten realm
i don't think there was a there was a
need for you to switch a character to be
honest but bombing was the character
that um
uh sorry
ling who was the character that
bumblebee played before kirimitsu came
out so let's see if uh that um
with that old school knowledge that he
has helped him out here now yeah fully
fully agree
obviously ling is really really good
against king phoenix can do so much
against him there's so much of the stuff
that she does that just completely
evades and gets out of situations king
likes to enforce all that being said and
done the reason why i don't like it is
that you had proof you had visual
evidence that your opponent did not know
your character and could not handle your
offense that was enough taken to the
next stage get the stage pick but either
way look hindsight is a great thing
bumblebee is looking like
it was a good pick so far one round up
until you punish that one nice
portable one
already threatening with it there is
again
yeah it does this does force the kings
to go for forward one plus two try and
lock down that movement put it into
crouching and force some mix-ups but you
just have to be so careful no punishment
while sending two two there
down that two
anti-link tech here
oh
do you one plus two will go into the
wall as well
back turn nice very very nice roller
side or the forward four again crushes
the low frankenstein and there we go
greetings is on the board
round three
one round a piece
one
doesn't get anything off that
oh nice stuff there the moonsault as
well great back bro catch shining wizard
instantly broken that was beautiful that
shiny wizard looked like it had to be a
giant swing oh no didn't finish the
combo one of the clean walls that messes
up great low power on the range drive
though greetings looking super good
against the ling right now
super awareness and very confident play
oh just the right wow this camera but no
punish this is one thing we're seeing
for bumpy punishment is not on point at
all right now
now for one two
the cali roll there it is this is
exactly what bumblebee needs it needs to
get started big combos big damage not
the best punish
or firecracker okay trying to set
something up the king wave dash
train grab what are we going for oh no
no no no no no no no he gets
him we're going round and round guys
this is going to be great for him as
well
what's the okay could jump over
no oh very very nice nice
punishment
again oh greetings oh gosh
oh the rdc oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh
god i didn't like it i didn't like it
i mean
yeah these things happen this is kevin
king's on the screen you should be ready
for it um unfortunately bumblebee wasn't
ready sometimes you're just mashing too
to break it and you just you just missed
you just missed the timing so hey whis
i'm talking to you on a private line
chat can't hear me right now
stop being negative about king i'm not
how i'm not being negative about you
stop being negative about king i'm a
king player
you're just you're just biased towards
king that's what's happened here that's
great you see my neutrality is negative
you know what i mean so
yeah
uh
anyway
getting into the matchup though great
great things i saw using up forward one
plus two at range can be dangerous can
get jabbed out of it but as it's great
if someone's moving around in phoenix
down forward one two it's ten frame
punishable i actually think that still
makes it a fantastic move even if you're
getting punished here and there you can
delay it you can mix it up into a throw
if you spam it it it it doesn't really
matter too much you're gonna have to
spam it a lot to die using that move um
and i i feel like he actually used some
really good anti-link straps yeah he
went straight back to
do you
just realize yep that wasn't the play at
all that was something you should be
doing going to the kunimitsu i
understand the decision it was it was a
weird
it was a weird i i i think it was just
wasting switch the you only lost a close
game on forgotten room against king and
you saw the greetings are still
struggling with some killing mitzvah
things so i just yeah i don't think um
i just don't think you could have
switched so early so let's see if
bumblebee all right they sent me text
frost knows about the cooner
let's see one two one as well getting
the frame traps going
nice block and punish there from
bumblebee tries to throw his way out
though
this pressure working out very well from
so far nice break on the shining wizard
you can't stay down but he had to break
that throw there that could have been
the the beginning of the end
oh he gets a jump by accident and just
like that bumblebee stays alive
like this three things just needs one
more game here to move into grand finals
winning side nice option to select a car
and get a follow-up
nice punishment
that's punished definitely
nice dark well shining wizard again
his instant shiny wizards are very
strong should we go for that more
they're not getting broken
yeah we're not seeing great thorough
breaks here from bumby
one two nice punish i think he had
counter hit there as well that could
have been big punish that
downford one greetings looking super
strong right now
i get the theme bumblebees breaking one
by default
and i think
if greetings abuses that then
it could work out pretty nasty it goes
about turn three doesn't matter into the
launch again very nice that and gets a
clean water spot i didn't expect that
bomb we can't get away from the moon so
oh the whole set one one two string hits
for some reason
nice
four three nice dark
not broken by greetings both there for a
break not the best right now and the
back roll catch greetings he didn't back
roll last time i'm surprised he went for
the cooney again the kunai again and so
was greetings
he hasn't converted look he's catching
bumblebee ducking now the mids of the
mids are coming online you've got to use
them
oh this is nice who counts here we're
going to the wall as well
i flopped
i think that was a giant swing there
finish that board
set three nice he knows it's not plus on
hit
oh he's going rolling again he's mad man
wait yes he needs to get back away from
the wall let me con doing just like that
bumby ties it all up at two two one
going to a final game
we are going to follow game and i just
can't i like that it worked out for
bumblebee but that side roll whilst king
had rage like in that situation i was
thinking to myself do not do that you've
already eaten some of this before but it
worked out for him nonetheless and we
are going to that final game i i can't
call this i
was that was very very close was
everyone who like saw that in slow
motion where i saw greetings back to the
wall
like bombay starts shuffling a bit has
rage available we just knew exactly what
was going to come out there
um yeah unfortunate therefore greetings
gets hit by the rage damn we're going to
a final game um but it's not the worst
case scenario for greetings because
you're probably just going to pick
forgotten realm again so we're gonna
have the pie stage for the final game
i'd i'd guess so i'd guess so and i
actually
as a king player
playing around that cooney rage drive is
really difficult you can't step it like
other characters might be able to well
walk
walk around it i wouldn't trust in
king's movement that way he's a wide guy
and his movement sideways isn't too
great so you kind of have to wait out
and try and get yourself away from the
wall and not eat too much of a mix-up
didn't work out for him then and we are
going to this final
game and as you say is it going to be
forgotten around
it is yep
yes his stage pick for the final game is
going to be really important really
going to decide how this goes
it's a pretty stage
it is but it's a dangerous you know
one wrong step and you go through the
floor
yeah king has two throws that will take
half a bar at least um if you get uh the
right okay after or the right juggle
after oh but there's that nice if i'm
gonna be smart he's just gonna take this
opportunity to just break the floor take
those floors away from king exactly what
he's doing here
heartbreaking if you're a king player
one gone nice option there as well and
this should be the
okay bumpy gets the perfect but he
probably should have broken another
floor there you know you have that
charge i thought just take them away
from king as much as you can yeah if
someone does the reset on you and then
also gets the second floor again it's
another heartbreaker gets the throw this
time oh is he gonna get it buddy oh
three i talked about this before just
one begins the party style oh this is
looking like going to be a triple
perfect this is going to be a god game
you're just cursing now it's not going
to happen
it's not well this is this could be no
one
realm it's not going to happen if the
bumblebee takes the second birthday just
going to do there it is see nice
okay i don't want to see it oh he screws
it up yeah messed up the powerbomb i
don't know what he's doing minus 10 no
punish guaranteeing great punished um
great throw break there by bumpy like
you said maybe he's just breaking one by
default because there's a shiny wizard
which he doesn't break
sidewall again
is defensive okay is the same pretty
much every time yeah nice too nice we're
punished
patience here
he doesn't finish it
oh nice
okay yeah that's good that was i i was
going to break the floor as well he's
just going to get the kill greetings is
on the board
ballsy move to go for you can screw that
up especially in that situation actually
concerning he messed up an easy power
bomb earlier so yeah
confidence is there
while 74
big knee oh i think we're going to get a
final round is to punish the hot knee
don't you curse it now choice i i wait
punish that
could have had more knives stuck in the
back one two and we're going to a final
final round to decide who goes into our
grand finals on winner's side is it
gonna be greetings is gonna be bumblebee
and look is getting too desperate for
the launches now not working out no
that's not the very nice scene
and now he's punishing that while
stunning three well doesn't get this
very wanted probably going for the
tombstone yeah they probably messed up
tombstone there
shiny wizard messed up
oh punish that not the best
it's a punish not the punish
nice again the options that the hawk
knee this isn't going to be the round
though but it's going to be big for
bumblebee going to put damage for
greetings in rage
qcf2 big damage
one two
race track gone down four two
and the dark and punished by bumblebee
and he moves forward into grand finals
winner side showing that that link pick
didn't hurt him too much he's still
alive here
and greetings goes down into the losers
final